so this story is from uh the other day
but it's just it's too much
quote for all we know he was some sort
of sex slave son of Paul Pelosi's
alleged attacker says his father is not
evil believes in human rights and is
hardly a right-wing conservative
so he said quote he isn't a danger to
society I don't even know if he even
attacked Mr Pelosi for all that we know
he was some sort of sex slave as Elon
Musk pointed out and then when I read
that I just
we had a conversation about this on the
show specifically saying hey he was
probably tied down hey Paul Pelosi was
probably doing really bad things to him
we were saying the same exact things
that his son is saying right now but
maybe his son is saying it because and
and and I'll clarify
I think that was you saying yes I did
yeah yeah I'm pretty sure Tim said it I
heard no no don't point the finger at me
I said don't give up I said don't give
him any any benefit of the doubt let's
let's go off with the craziest things
and let's say that's a possibility here
because of the absence of evidence
because they're hiding so much
information because they're changing
their story time and time again because
they're they're suspending the NBC
reporters
who still hasn't come back to work yeah
he's still punished because he reported
on what police officers were telling him
actually happened on that particular day
so when you have very rich powerful
people you'd never give them the benefit
of the doubt we shouldn't hear and what
his son says I mean it's important to
pay attention to he also goes on talked
about how his father the person accused
here believes in equality Justice how he
was an activist against the war how he
was a peace activist he was quote hardly
a right-wing conservative both when we
look at the media they framed this
entire attack as we need to go after all
the conspiracy theorists these
conspiracy theorists are dangerous these
conservatives are dangerous we need to
stop them right now that's the narrative
that they were going with that that's
the agenda that they were going with and
it failed right on its face I think the
conservative mention is what really is
like a red light to me that they mention
and call him a right-wing activist is
like it puts everything else into
question about the story not that it
should because maybe they're just
picking one thing and but he's obviously
like a green party the other way you
know that there's a lot more going on
here is that the story just disappeared
immediately right because what they told
us was that uh that the Speaker of the
House of Representatives had her home
invaded so that someone could murder her
so if that if that actually happened
it just seems to me like the sort of
thing that we ought to be talking about
a little bit more but then when these
details came out like when NBC reported
that Paul Pelosi himself opened the door
did not seem to be in distress walked
back to his alleged attacker when it
came out that this this attacker
actually wasn't some right winger he was
living on some weird sort of rainbow
colored commune type thing when all of
these when you heard the dispatch phone
call then all of a sudden the story just
completely went away yep just like just
like Club Q just like the Las Vegas
shooting just like so many other large
events that we somehow don't want to
talk about now very conveniently they
just sell tickets I mean there's just
it's impossible to improve a lot of the
stuff they claim because there's no
video they have a story that works uh
towards their benefit that they're going
to use and emotionally exploit in order
to push for a certain agenda once those
version of events are different they
don't have their conclusion that they
conveniently came up with as soon as the
event happened right away
so sorry I just want to explain what
happened well they're they're trying to
drive a cultural shift a narrative and
when they can't they can't and they stop
for re for record I mean I believe the
Pelosi's when they're not home they have
security at the house even when they're
not there they're one of the richest
people in the world to think that they
don't have Securities is absolutely
crazy no no but think about this too
look at what's going on with Elon some
dude attacked his kid yeah and he posted
the video about it for obvious reasons
elon's got crazy security you think the
Pelosi's after especially with their
hype of January 6 they didn't have
security or something they've got to I
mean Pelosi was calling for machine guns
at the Capitol literally every single
semi-buji Millennial has
so many camera security systems around
his home constantly recording on their
phones all the time anybody who is at
all in political prominence has heavy
security if not 24 7 home security
you're telling me that the person third
in line to the U.S presidency just
Whoopsie Daisy didn't have any cameras
and didn't have any I just absurd can I
I want to point this out too the New
York Times reported the other day quote
how did I get into all of this Mr depap
wrote in one passage on his blog
gamergate it was gamergate I love that
because nobody who actually knew
anything about gamergate would come out
and be like I was radicalized by
gamergate like that's just not a way
that sounds like something who is not
paying attention to the culture War it
sounds like something they would say to
make you like they think they're
convincing you right
um it's like it's like a patriot front
right yeah you kind of you say you know
I was radicalized by the Q a non-gamer
gate insurrectionist Patriot front is
that hey Quantico is that what I was
supposed to say okay good got it is
gamergate when the Communist man
basically slid into the American
Zeitgeist was gamergate was at the first
moment where we start to see this like
social this weird social movement
gamergate was like some chick slept with
some guy in exchange for a positive
review of her game yeah
right right no but like and so
somehow it turned into
what happens is you get a lot of people
then pointing out that these woke
journalists are writing this fake
wokeness stuff and it becomes somewhat
culture worry like it does elevate to
that point but like the initial issue of
gamergate this makes no sense yeah it's
like somebody who read a Wikipedia entry
about the culture war is trying to
convince you that they were a part of it
from the beginning no the weirdest thing
about this is if the if the guy's Kids
come out and say he's not a conservative
he's a green party guy but this guy is
going into court and saying that he was
going to Target Tom Hanks and Gavin
Newsom I don't believe him like hmm it's
here's the funny thing this guy goes to
court and makes these claims about
gamergate or whatever he hasn't a Blog I
think not he's making the claims but
apparently he had a list I'm like you
expect me to believe the guy who you
claim attacked Paul Pelosi he sounds
crazy I'm sorry I'm not going to believe
this I think this is a key here too
because people are trying to construct
really sophisticated narratives about
what's going on but is it not possible I
humbly propose that this guy is kind of
crazy he's like a crazy guy I think
that's possible yeah see that's one
explanation I I have a different
explanation and it goes kind of further
down the rabbit hole to say the least
and I think it should go down the rabbit
hole especially with how powerful how
Sinister how absolutely evil The Core
Power inside of the United States really
is especially with all the private
islands that they go to we and we only
are scratching up the surface to the
true reality of what's Happening behind
the scenes there so I never give them
the benefit benefit of the doubt let's
just speculate here hey he was a sex
slave he was picked off off the street
he was living in a van he was going to
be sacrificed he was going to be
tortured he was going to be forced on by
Paul Pelosi because I'm doing what the
corporate media is doing the corporate
media did that as soon as the story
broke they said we have in the narrative
who we we know exactly what happened he
did it because he hated him because he
was a right winger they're doing it I'm
gonna do it my way and I'll bet my
bottom dollar right now my weight's
probably a lot more correct than they
are I got it we should do a skit called
like you know uh it should be called
something we'll call it captive the
depap story and it's like a guy's
kidnapped and dragged into this house
and it'll be like that scene from Pulp
Fiction you know you guys know where I'm
going with this I'm kidding look my view
of this is The Simple Solution is it's a
crazy guy you know what I mean I
understand your point though Luke don't
give them go don't give them the benefit
of the doubt if they're not going to
release the video so we can see what
happens in a world where creepypeto
Island exists and in a world where
everything I know we're on YouTube so
I'll be really super careful where
um every single thing we've been told by
anyone in Authority for the past two and
a half years is totally fake uh in a
world then in in that world it is
reasonable it is more reasonable to
assume that Paul and Nancy Pelosi every
single night are whipping and torturing
this random guy than it is to believe
the CNN thank you absolutely and they
also have the Bohemian Grove you know
what they do with the Bohemian girl mock
child sacrifices to molec as they walk
around naked in the woods that's
literally what happens and it's
documented so you know you're forcing me
to disagree but I only disagree a little
because I agree with the the the points
both of you make why are we going to
trust the New York Times Are CNN after
everything they've lied about so I would
I would put it this way
I am willing to say fine this guy's kid
says for all we know he was a sex slave
and they need to produce the evidence to
produce to prove otherwise now in all
sincerity I think this guy's probably
just a crazy person yeah and I think if
there was a story that made sense
outside of the official narrative or the
conspiracy theory drug deal gone wrong
yeah his son I think said the David the
pap son said that David was like abused
growing up I think he lived with his
grandparents and they were real abusive
so he would spend his days away from
home at the ocean just like waiting for
them to be asleep by the time he gets
home a messed up guy like messed up in
his childhood kind of guy uh most same
people don't like jump at the
opportunity to go deal drugs to a
politician or sexual politician most 10
people would not would not want to spend
any time near the Pelosi it's too
dangerous I mean just for your own
Lively let's just break something down
real quick right
I just want I don't want to believe
anything I want proof and so I'm willing
to say your official narrative in the
courts is total bunk BS because you've
not explained anything properly or given
us video footage but to me if I was
gonna if I'm looking at a roulette wheel
with a bunch of different outcomes for
the story and I got to put my chips down
I'm putting it on why aren't there why
isn't there footage of it Paul turned
the cameras off because he was buying
drugs where are the security guards Paul
told them to go take a walk because his
drug dealers showing up if I went to you
and said do you think prominent people
are doing drugs
like everyone says yes to that but
couldn't I my only problem with that
theory is couldn't a Pelosi get a posh
or drug dealer you know when I I think
of my friends in New York and La over
the years who've who have been
pharmaceutical you know they always go
to some like Rich fancy guy maybe but
think about this too the guy was a green
party leftist right yeah so if if you're
someone like Pelosi and you need
discretion you also want to make sure
you've got someone who's not going to go
it's Paul Pelosi who can throw under the
bus later not so much that but someone
that is less likely like I'm not going
to invite a GrubHub driver over here
who's got an antifa profile you know
what I mean we don't want to let someone
of those ideas we want to make sure that
so for the most part we're not really
worried about deliveries I'm just saying
right I I'm not saying it's it's true or
guaranteed I'm just saying I lean
towards I bet dude called up his connect
and said you know he wanted Coke or
something told security guard say take a
walk that's why there's no security
there the reason why he told the cops I
don't know who he is he's a friend is
because he invited him over but was not
familiar with who he was the reason why
he answers the door politely and says
we're taking care of it is because he
doesn't want things to get you know I
just I kind of feel like dude was buying
drugs Michael though these people have
handlers these people have Associates
these people got got people that do
everything for them at the snap of a
finger if you tell a Handler hey go get
me this they'll go get it so that's the
people that they have in Washington DC
why wouldn't they have it in San
Francisco to me again why are we
speculating we shouldn't be speculating
we should be calling for more evidence
we shouldn't be giving them the benefit
of the doubt if we're going to be having
a conversation here worst possible
scenario always
um and that that's I think you know
what's going to happen we're not going
to find out any more information the
story is just going to disappear because
it doesn't serve their narrative and
it's really weird and it raises a lot of
questions about them but they wrote a
hit piece about us because we were
talking about this subject you know a
week or so ago or two weeks ago the
leftist media machine starts writing you
know Tim cast IRL pushing insane
conspiracies and it's I'm sorry guys in
the media if you don't have anything to
actually say you can't say anything
about us if if if you're like we have no
evidence we have no idea what happens
but it's it's whatever the government
said it doesn't fly and I don't care
what you think no it's too it's too
dangerous to make claims about what
happened this guy's life's on the line
right now David to Pap like he could go
away to prison for the rest of his life
this guy's about they're about to they
want to just put it all on him I mean In
fairness though three Hots in a cot
might not be the worst thing for this
guy like he was not living a flourishing
lifestyle beforehand so David de pope
did not Epstein himself I'm calling it
here where's his phone I want to see the
records was he texting yeah you know
before texting uh what's his name what's
what's Pelosi Paul's Paul's phone and
Paul by the way made a spectacular
recovery apparent looking he seems to
have I saw a picture of him and Nancy
and he looks fine we also have to
realize we're dealing with people that
uh suspend journalists at end NBC News
and make them not come back to their
work okay that's how powerful these
people are and you know but by the way
you're telling me they're telling the
truth here the way that's being covered
is oh NBC made a mistake and then they
edited it and got this wasn't like a
typo in an article there was a fully
fleshed out several minutes long TV News
segment where an investigative
journalist went in and covered Moment by
moment what happened and then with no
explanation whatsoever NBC just pulled
the record at another media organization
yeah yeah and another media organization
covered it as well did the same
reporting based off police sources that
NBC reporter he wasn't making things up
he wasn't speculating he was like I
talked to this police officer and this
police officer and I saw this police
report he was documenting what actually
was being reported thanks for watching
this clip from the timcast IRL podcast
hang out with us live Monday through
Friday at 8 pm and become a member over
at timcast.com for uncensored members
only shows exclusive thanks for hanging
out and we'll see you all next time